Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on really
[Music]
[Music]
an exorcist did he slip and fall no she
was thrown in
[Music]
[Music]
here I come
yo we found our murderer
elephants been hunting it down
[Music]
ah
[Music]
- I would
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I won't die yet not until I have my
revenge revenge
the bastards at the guild who tried to
kill me they want me to take the fall
for their smuggling operation wait are
you saying the whole guild was involved
of course ha ha ha you think a
second-rate sailor like me could pull
off all that mischief by myself I mean
sure I was in on it helping them wasn't
without its benefits he has a point it
would take more than one person to dig
that tunnel into the warehouse problem
is our extra legal activities were a
little too successful the abbey was
bound to notice us at some point and
dead men tell no tales
so they blame it on you and kill you to
cover it up looks like it's not going
quite how they planned how do you mean
to get this revenge of yours the raid on
hella V's I'll kill the lot of them this
I swear that would be suicide do you
have any idea how many exorcists are
around they'll hunt me down no matter
what I do I just want the guild to pay
for what they did to me
[Music]
that's all I wanted but I guess even
that's not gonna work out we'll take
this back to town and tell him you're
dead that should be enough to satisfy
the Exorcist and get them to call off
the search but why I have my reasons we
need a boat fixed for starters plus if
you stir things up after I leave I
imagine it'll slow down anyone who's
following me if that's what you want
miss I won't let you down
[Music]